à québec la première ministre pauline
marois souhaite que le vérificateur
général ne dépose pas son rapport comme
prévu sur la mise à jour économique
jeudi
pourquoi parce qu' un dépôt de budget
qui est prévue jeudi
sébastien en fait la première ministre
assez inusité demandé au vérificateur
général de presser le pas un peu la wii
elle l'a fait publiquement mais le
gouvernement refuse de faire une demande
formelle au vérificateur général ce qui
nous engage dans un dialogue de sourd je
vous explique le contexte
en effet jeudi à la présentation du
budget mais aussi le rapport du vg sur
la mise à jour économique du mois de
novembre et le gouvernement ne veut pas
être taxé de vouloir porter ombrage au
rapport du vérificateur général en
présentant le même jour son budget alors
il souhaiterait que le vecteur général
présente son rapport demain ou après
demain sauf que le vg est à l'abri de
l'influencé politique en principe il
sera pourquoi la première ministre le
vérificateur général il se rapporte au
président de l'assemblée nationale il
est nommé par le président par
l'assemblée nationale et madame marois
en ne faisant pas de demande formelle ne
veux pas avoir l'air de d'influencer le
vérificateur général et le vg tant qu'il
n'y a pas de demande formelle bas il
bougera pas voici ce que madame marois
pense de la stratégie du vétérinaire
très étonné qu'il ne le fasse pas et
j'ai demandé aux mines et des finances
aussi que puisse indiquer que nous
souhaitons que le vérificateur général
dépose son analyse le plus tôt possible
et l'ironie c'est que le vérificateur
général va déposer donc peut-être je dis
peut-être avant une étude sur les
chiffres qui ont été déposées par le
ministre des finances il ya quelques
mois sur la mise à jour économique la
journée d'un budget oui il aurait vite
mena c'est ça les chiffres sur lesquels
des f4 général va se pencher seront
caducs
à partir du moment où le budget sera
déposé par le gouvernement
cela dit sébastien donc budget je dis ça
s'est confirmé et il y aurait dans l'air
un déclenchement peut-être pas quelques
jours après mais quelques semaines après
ouais et chose certaine ça va aller à la
bourse cette semaine parce que le
gouvernement a beaucoup de pain sur la
planche s'il veut présenter demain sa
politique sur la sécurité civile dont
david gêne-t-il et nous révéler les
grandes lignes à quelques jours déjà sa
politique sur l'immigration mercredi
peut-être la politique sur l'itinérance
déposé un projet de loi sur les régimes
de retraite mercredi ou jeudi
faire adopter le projet de loi sur les
soins en fin de vie et présenter le
budget jeudi c'est énorme ça comme menu
législatif d'ici jeudi
et à partir du moment où le budget
déposé bien là les spéculations
électorales reprennent avec un
déclenchement possible le 26 février
mais on a l'impression qu'un si vous
posez la question aujourd'hui on serait
plus tenté de déclencher autour du 5
mars les élections pour un scrutin le 7
avril
mais on est un peu dans le brouillard
sur cette question là on a l'impression
que la décision de madame marois
peut-être même pas encore prise de façon
définitive donc d'aller quelques jours
pour les députés en congé en pause
allait voir leurs électeurs et des clans
gendre le budget eau a déclenché quelque
part autour du 5 6 mars la voilà ce
serait le 5 mars parce que ces mercredi
et mercredi en conseil des ministres qui
adoptent le décret pour déclencher des
élections
voilà parions sur le 5 mars disent
d'accord sébastien on se reparle
évidemment demain au revoir